This is Jocko podcast number 26.
With Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Oh,
for a voice like funder and to tongue to
drown the throat of war when the senses
are shaking and the soul
is driven to madness.
Who can stand when the soles of the
oppressed fight in the troubled air that
rages,
who can stand when the whirlwind of
fury comes from the throne of God,
when the frowns of his countenance
drive the nations together who can stand
when sin claps his broad wings over the
battle and sales rejoicing in the flood
of death,
when souls are torn to everlasting
fire and feelings of hell,
rejoice upon the slain.
Oh,
who can stand?
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
That right there is a little excerpt
of a poem by a guy named William Blake
and it paints war as
uh, something so powerful. So evil,
something is super human
in the full poem is really a statement
against warning as it goes on.
And it's not that much longer,
but it blames war on the politicians and
on the kings and on the nobles and it
blames war on the religious leaders.
But he asked that question over
and over again who can stand
and I can actually answer that question
and I've seen who can stand.
I've seen people break,
but I've seen many brave men and
women on the battlefield stand,
stand against fear and
death and stand against evil
stand as sin claps his broad wings over
the battle and sales rejoicing in the
flood of death.
And that's William Blake.
Those are his words,
but he's writing that in the
late 17 hundreds and early
1,802 he had no idea how
bad war would get.
Okay?
And I'm not saying war is worse
in terms of individual horror,
but in terms of scale,
Mick can't be denied.
I mean World War One and World War Two,
the scale of horror,
it would be in comprehensible
to two man from Blake's time,
he just couldn't understand it.
So let's go to June 6th
okay.
As the demon spread his wings
over the beaches of Normandy
and men stood against his evil,
the English Cox,
and tried to drop the ramp a couple of
hundred feet from the shore when the
sergeant ordered.
Take us all the way in.
Just then machine guns opened up and
bullets tore through the wooden sides of
the landing craft wounding. Four or
five men, men be began screaming,
opened the damn doors.
Just as the ramp went down,
there was a pause in the incoming fire.
We exited fast diving into
the water and holding on.
Sergeant Trona was lying next to me
when he was shot through the wrist.
I crawled over to him
and gave him first aid.
We just let the tide wash over the
lower portion of our bodies using our
fingernails to pull.